13, 14, 15e heure. Je vous
invite à écouter mon reportage
qui explique le fond de ce
- Ici, la pression augmente
depuis des années, tellement
que l'urgence de M
possible rupture de service.
ANNIE FOURNIER, infirm. urgence
Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont
- J'ai pas peur de le dire :
on s'en va. J'espère qu'ils vont
riririririririririririririririrt
un ultimatum.EnEnEnEnEnviron 90s
menacent de démissionner.
Elles ont signé une pétition,dé.
Parce qu'ici, le temps
supplémentaire, obligatoire ou
non, est devenu trop important.
- Je crois qu'on devrait fermer
l'urgence pour quelques jours,
po
sesesesese avec l'équipe,
toutes les équipes.- - - - - L'e
que l'urgence de Maisonneuve-
Rosemont reçoit quotidiennement
que sa capacité.
CHRISTIAN , , , , , , , , , , ,c
- Alors, quand vous regardez
l'urgesosososososonneuve-
Rosemont, je les comprends
d'être découragé, par ce que
c'IlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlI.
- Dimanche, le ministre
t t t t t t que Maisonneuve-
Rosemont est devenu beaucoup
trop petit. Et estimaitititititt
changer sa gestion des horaires.
Mais le syndicat pense que ça ne
règle pas le problème de fond.
DENIS CLOUTIER, prés., Syndicat
professionnelles en soins, FIQ
- Il nous manque du monde, c'e
c'est pas des choses comme
l'autogestion des horair
a été suggéré par le ministre qi
que ce soit à ça.
- Québec solidaire pense que
le g t t t t t t t t t t t t t t
de Montréal.
VINCENT MARISSAL, porte-parole
de QS en matière de santé
- Je pense que la gest
ce qu'ils ont. Le ministre par
contre est aux abo.......
La CAQ a abandonné l'est de
Montréal. Le m
Santé a abandonné l'Hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont.
- Difficile, dans ce contexte,
de régler la pénurie de
qui ont l'embarras du choix,
ne sont peut-être pas
intéressées à travailler
tututututututututututututututut.
Ici Davide Gentile,
R